Yeah,
nuclear power nuclear power that we have
now,
it's called second generation nuclear
power.
Um,
it's um,
it's a comparable in cost to coal.
Once you have the nuclear power plant,
then the fuel is very inexpensive,
so nuclear power is quite inexpensive,
but it's difficult in the United States
to get a nuclear power plant and build
and it takes so many years that it
drives the cost up.
So now in England they've realized that
they will need to have nuclear power in
the future,
so they've put a limit once a government
commission decides on where the power
plants will be built,
the public will have one year to object
to this and possibly get some changes,
but they can't drag it out six or seven
years the way it happens in the United
States because that drives up the price
tremendously.
And there's also the possibility for
fourth generation nuclear power.
That's a technology which allows you to
burn all of the nuclear fuel.
Presently,
nuclear power plants burn less than one
percent of the energy in the nuclear
fuel.
Fourth generation nuclear power allows
the neutrons to move faster so they can
burn all of the fuel and furthermore it
can burn nuclear waste so it can solve
the nuclear waste problem,
and the United States is still the
technology leader in fourth generation
nuclear power in 1994 Argonne National
Laboratory now called Idaho National
Laboratory was ready to build a fourth
generation nuclear power plant,
but the Clinton Gore administration
canceled that research because of the
anti nuclear sentiments in the
Democratic Party,
what?
Well,
we are still have the best expertise in
that technology and we should develop it
because it's something that we could
also sell to China,
India,
because they're going to need nuclear
power.
They don't are not going to be able to
get all of their energy from the sun and
from the wind.
The most effective one is energy
efficiency.
We waste a lot of our energy.
We can get vehicles that get more miles
per gallon there.
There are many ways to improve energy
efficiency.
In fact,
some states are twice as efficient as
other states.
Just because fossil fuels were so cheap,
we just didn't pay attention to how
effectively we were using them,
but in addition,
they're renewable energies,
solar energy,
wind energy,
and I think that nuclear power has to be
part of the solution because at this
time it's the only alternative to coal
for baseload electrical power,
and we do now have the technology for a
much safer and more efficient nuclear
power as compared to the old versions
that were used in the past several
decades.